반드시 좀 이걸 확인해 보실 필요가
있습니다
진짜 급한 거예요 이거 사실
재무제표가 나왔냐
[음악]
제가 오늘은 그 부동산 임대 법인을
운영하시는 분들이 반드시 알아야 돼요
포인트가 있어서
회계사님이 최근에 좀 급하게 연락을
주셨어요 일단 회계사님 굉장히 좀
오랜만에 여기서
찍는 건 제가 처음이에요 다 이제
역삼에서 찍을 때였고 좋습니다 지금
회계사님이 부동산 임대 법인은 지금
몇 개 정도 관리하고 지금 제가 이제
부동산 임대법인 이제 세무대리 소위
말해서 기장을 맡고 있는게 100개
정도 100개 정도 되고 있습니다
배경 설명을 드리면 지금 이제
2022년 1월 1일부터 12월
31일까지의 이제 결산을 해서 3월
말일까지 이제 법인세 신고하는 거예요
그래서 아직은 신고가 안 들어갔어요
다 모든 세무회계사무소가
회계법인이 다 결산을 진행 중일텐데
어쨌든 아직 신고가 안 들어갔기
때문에이 영상을 보시고 보시는 분들의
세무대리인한테 한번 확인 전화 한번
하셔야 됩니다 제가 봤을 때
보면은 오늘 이제 알려드릴 거 첫
번째는 이제 부시지무기업 판단
요건이에요 이게 이제 전 금융기관이
똑같다라고는 이제 말씀을 못 드리는데
크게 다르진 않을 거예요 왜냐
그러면은 이제 이런 가이드라인은 보통
금감원에서 줘요 여러분들의
금융기관에 뭐 신한은행이든 kb든 뭐
전혀 상관없을 것 같고요 아마
우리나라에 있는 거의 대부분
금융기관은이 요건을 따를거다라고
생각하시면 될 것 같습니다 그래서
일단은 부실 징후 기업에 해당이
되면은 대출을 상환해야 되는 거잖아요
뭐 일부 상환 요청이 들어올 수도
있고요 만기 전이라도 아니면은
금리가 올라갈 수도 있고 만기가
됐더라도 더 이상 연장이 안 돼요라고
할 수 있는 거고 연장은 안 되면은
근데 이제 그때 되면은 다른
금융기관도 돈을 빌려줄까라는 생각은
있어요 왜냐면 내가 지금 빌리고 있는
은행은 나를 가장 잘 아는 은행일
거고 그리고 내가 들고 간 재무제표를
보고 아 대출이 제가 못 빌려 드릴
것 같아요라고 했는데
과연이 재무제표를 들고 다른
금융기관에 가서
돈을 빌릴 수 있을까 그래서 만기
전이라도 사실 알고 계셔야 됩니다
최근에 금리가 좀 많이 올랐잖아요
많이 올랐죠 사실
2022년도부터 쭉 올랐잖아요 저도
정말 여기까지 올랐네 저도요
언제까지 이러다 정말 다 죽을 거
같거든요 그거는 저희가 통제할 수
없는 거고
은행이 생각하는 부시징의 기업 요건을
세 가지를 한번 제가 설명드릴게요이
세 가지는 and가 아니에요 셋 중에
하나입니다
첫 번째 최근 결산이 현재
납입자문이
완전자본잠식이다 아마 자본잠식이라는
표현은 들어보셨을 거예요
근데 이게
은행에서 생각하는
요건 3개 중에 하나다 요게 어떤
건지는 뒤에서 재무제표를 실제로 보고
제가 설명을 드릴게요
근데 이름만 들어도 조금 무섭죠 완전
자본 잠식
완전 돈이 없는 거죠 뭐
풀어서 설명드리면 이런 겁니다 저희가
법인을 설립했을 때 자본금이라는 걸
넣었을 거예요 자본금을 설정하잖아요
뭐 이런 뭐 3억 5억이 정도
설정하실 텐데이 자본금보다 누적
손실이 더 많은 거예요
그러니까 이런 거죠 최초의 제가
자본금을 1억으로 해서 부동산
임대범을 설립했어요 그리고 대출을
받고 건물 샀어요
근데
운용하다 보니까
임대료보다이자 비용이 너무 큰 거예요
아니면 다른 비용이 너무 큰 거예요
그래서 내가 누적으로 1억 이상을
까먹었어 예를 들자면 손실이 한 2년
해보니까 손실이 누적으로 1억 5천이
됐어요
근데 내가 최초의 자본금 부은 건
얼마죠 1억이죠 그럼
자본잠식이에요 마이너스
5천 뜬 거잖아요 이런 거를 이제
은행은 보겠다는 거예요 이런 법인은
부시징으로 보겠다 그래서 한 가지
팁이 자본금을 좀 여유 있게
설정하시는게 좋아요
모든 비용을 다 차감했을 때 남는 돈
이게 3년 연속 너가 손실이야 이거는
부시지무 기업으로 보겠다 이런 거야
그래서 여기서 주의해져야 할 것은
그런 거예요 또 상담을 나눠보면
법인카드를 그렇게 많이 쓰고 싶어요
또 두 번째 뭐냐면
리스 차를 엄청 뽑고 싶다
법인카드 써도 되나요 저 리스 뽑아도
되나요
근데 그게 결국에는 부담으로 돌아와요
왜냐면 내가 임대료는 고정되어
있잖아요 이자도 고정되어 있죠 사실
이전 어찌 보면 변동으로 했으면 계속
올라오고 안 그래도 돈이 없는데 안
그래도 손실이 날 것 같은데 거기에
내가
돈을 더 쓴다 그거는 제가 봤을 때는
다시 생각해봐요 저는 항상 강의할
때도
법인카드랑 미스 뽑지 말라고 해요
이유는 첫 번째 이게 있고 어찌됐든
저희가 부시지무기업에 해당되면 대출을
회수 당하거나
금리가 올라가는 거잖아요 이제 그게
첫 번째였고 두 번째는 저희는 이제
성실신고 대상 법인이라서 다
국세청에서 모니터링을 합니다 그리고
이제 사적 경비를 쓰게 되면
근데 오늘 이제 지퍼 드릴 거는
국세청에서
성실신고라서 너에게 사적 경매 많이
썼냐이 포인트보다는
은행에서 뭐라고 한다
은행에서 너 왜 이렇게 손실이 났니
세 번째는 이게 어찌보면 가장
핵심인데 2년 연속 영업이익이
금융비용의 미달하게
맨날 생각하시는게
임대료가이자 비용보다 크냐 작냐는
따지거든요
맨날 건물 살 때도 보면은 여기
임대료 얼마 나와요 2억 나온다
1년에 근데 내가 이렇게 차입해서 내
금리 따져보니까 1억 5천 나와
이자가 그러면 얼마 남는 거예요
근데
막상 사보면
5천이 안 나와 그죠 다 빠지죠
왜냐면 재산세 내야 사부작사부적
돈이 나가요 관리비나가지 저희 같은
사람들 세무 수수료 줘야지 그리고 나
이제 뭐 법인카드 좀 쓰지 여러분들이
임대료랑이자 비용을 비교하시는데 물론
이것도 중요해요 근데 은행에서는
영업이익이이자 비용보다 크냐 장난치죠
영업이익은 어떤 거냐면 받는
임대료에서
재산세 건물 관리비 수선비 이런
것들을 차감한
진짜 네트로이 건물이 얼마 남아
요거랑이자 비용을 비교하는 거예요
그래서 여러분들이 관점이
임대료랑이자 비용을 단순히 비교하시면
안 돼요 은행은 그것만 보진 않습니다
완전 순수익의 사실 그게 합리적인 거
아니에요 왜냐면 일반 기업이
은행에서 돈을 빌릴 때이 요건을 봐요
영업이익이이자 비용보다 몇 배인가
이거를 이제이자 보상 비율이라고
하거든요 만약에 영업이익이 다 털고
1년에 2억 남아
근데
빌려주는 금융기관 입장에서는 내가
이거 빌려주면 1년에 이자가 한 1억
정도 생길 것 같아
그러면 은행 입장에서는
얘네가 1 2억씩 버는데
레이저는 1억밖에 안 되니까
그래도 조금 안전하겠다라는 생각이 들
거잖아요 그런 거랑 똑같은 개념이에요
그래서
단순히 이자랑 임대료랑 비교하는 거는
이제 안 된다 올해 제가 왜 이거를
반드시 알려드려야겠다 생각했냐면
제작년 21년까지만 해도 사실
태평성대였던 거야 지금 돌이켜보면
금리가
[음악]
정말
천국이었죠 이제 작년 중수부도 쭉
올라가면서
추가적인 금리 인상은 뭐 안 될지언정
금리가 떨어질 거라는 가능성은 많이
없다고 보잖아요이 높아진 금리가
유지될거다라는 컨센서스가 많기 때문에
앞으로도 부실 징후기업 판단은 반드시
체크하고 계셔야 됩니다
그러니까 이게 사실 여기까진 생각을
대부분 못했거든요 못하죠 사기에만
급급하고 왜냐면 제가 이제 왜 이거를
못했지 왜 저도 이거를 그렇게 주면서
생각 안 했지 해 보니까
금리가 낮았으니까 이런 거를 알고
있지 않아도 그냥 자동 패스였던 거
이거는 은행에서 이제 전산으로
돌아가는 숫자일 텐데 그냥 당연히
패스 패스 패스 패스
근데 이제는 상황이 좀 바뀌었다
고급니 시대에는
금융기관이 생각하는 포인트를 알아야
된다
특히 왜 또 3년이 중요하냐면요
은행에서 돈 빌려 보시면 아시겠지만
만기가 보통 3년이에요 이제
22년도에 샀으면은 지금쯤 이제
만기가 도래요 이제 24년 초나
그러면 이제 내가 리볼빙을 해야 될
거잖아
근데 예를 들자면 어 들고 갔어이
회사는 부시지옥의 것 같다 그래서 뭐
예를 들자면 지금 35빌리셨는데
저희가 리볼빙 할 때는 25억 밖에는
못 빌려 드릴 것 같아요라고 할 수도
있는 거고 아니면 아 제가 30억은
그대로
빌려드릴게요 근데 금리가
7%는 내셔야 될 겁니다라고 할 수도
있는 거고 여러분들한테 제가 재무제표
설명을 간단하게 딱 5분만
설명드릴게요 보면은
읽어봐도 잘 안 와닿아요 뭐 부가세
예수금 선 그래서
재무제표는 딱
알아들어요 지금 제가 설명해 드리는
것만 알고 계시면 됩니다
첫 번째
재무제표는 두 가지가 있어요 하나는
재무상태표 아 또 하나는 손익계산서
재무상태표는 이런 거예요
야 너 12월 31일자 기준으로 너네
회사에 자산부채가 얼마야 자본금이
얼마야라는 거를 기재하는 거예요
그래서
특정 시점 일이에요 12월 31일
현재
딱 하루 하루에 대한 스냅샷이라고
생각하시면 돼요 아 그래서 여기 써
있네요네 12월 31일 현재 그래서
이거를 보시면 저희 이제 고객사건데
자산이 86억이에요 근데 유형자산이
84억이에요 즉 이거는 건물이 한
84억 정도의 사신 거예요 그래서
여러분은 생각하셨을 때 아 내가 산
토지와 건물의 금액이 여기 자산총액의
기재되는구나 딱 그것만 아시면 돼요
두 번째 부채라는게 있어요 부채
부채가 뭐죠 돈 빌린 거예요 돈 빌린
거잖아요 근데 건물 살 때 다 자기
돈을 사는 사람 없죠
어떻게 보면은 두 가지 하나는
금융기관한테 빌리고 또 하나는 내가
가수금으로 집어넣은게 있어요 그게
표시되는게 부채 쪽에 표시됩니다
그래서 여기 보시면
장기 차입금이라고 아 이게 대출금
64억 그러니까 아이 사람은
84억짜리 건물을 사면서 60석
정도로 빌렸나보다라는 걸 이제 알 수
있는 거고요 내가 넣은 가수금은
주임종 단기 차입금 15 15억을
넘는구나 주임종은 뭐의 약자일까요
주임종 주임종
뭘까
줄줄 2만 종업원
돈을 회사가 돈을 빌리는 데는 크게
두 가지예요 하나는 은행 하나는
내부산업
임원 종업원
가수금은 정확한 명칭은 아니고요
일상에서 쓰는 언어고 정확한 표현은
주임종 단기 차이입니다 부채 이런게
기재됐고 세 번째가 자본인데요 자본은
크게 보면 두 가지 하나는 자본금
자본금은 여러분들이 다
익숙하실 거예요 최초 설립할 때 넣는
돈 그리고 또 하나는 여기는 이제
손실이 나는데 미처리 결손
그러니까이 회사로 놓고 보면 자본금이
5억이에요
근데 미처리 결성금이
8,900만원이에요 어떤 거냐면
내가이 회사 설립할 때
5억 자본금을 설립해 놨는데 이게
지금 2기거든요 누적 동안 2년 동안
8,900만원의 손실난 거예요
그렇게 치면 완전 자본잠식일까요 부분
자본 잠식일까요 두 분이지 않을까요
부분 자본자로 그래서 여러분들이
재무상태 배우실 때는
크게 딱 세 군데만 보시면 돼요
아니요 하나만 보시면 돼요
맨 아래 자본총계
자본 총계가 양수면 완전자본잠식이
아니다이 자본 총계가 음수로 떠 있는
애들이 있어요 내가 납입한 자본금보다
손실액이 더 큰 거야 그래서 자본
총계는 마이너스야
음수를 완전 자본 잡혀요 그래서 나는
재무상태표를 딱 받았는데
뭘 봐야 될지 모르겠다 뭐 자산 이런
거 잘 모르겠
그럼 자본 잠식이다
완전자본점식은 아니다 두 번째
손익계산서라는 재물 지표가 있어요
손익계산서는
플로우에 정확하게 치면은 1월
1일부터 12월 31일까지예요
그러니까
재무상태표는 어느 특정일자의 스냅샷
같은 거라면은 손익계산서는 동영상
같은 거예요 1년 동안이 회사가
임대료가 얼마 들어왔고이자 비용을
얼마 썼고 재산세를 얼마 냈고 이런게
기재되어 있는 거예요 그래서 보시면
여기는 다르죠 1월 1일부터
12월까지
쭉 보시면 이건 그냥 오히려
손익계산서는 여러분들의 직관과
일치예요 이게 사실 근데 법인 더
편하네요 이게 우리가 생각하는
직관이거든 맨 처음 매출액 이건
뭘까요이
회사로 보면 임대료가 얼마죠 2억
900 2억 900 2억 정도 나오는
회사 나오는 건물이다
쭉 보다 보면은 어려운 용어나
판매비와 관리비 판매비와 관리비 한번
보면은 통신비 수도광열비 전력비
세금과 공과 보험료
지급 수수료 건물관리비
즉 여러분들이 이자비용 말고 들어가는
비용들이
판매 관리비에 들어요 아까 말한
여러분들은 맨날 임대료랑이자 비용만
비교하시잖아요
그러면 안 된다고 영업이 영업이익이
뭐죠
임대료에서
요런 비용을 다 제한거를 영업입니다
그래서이 회사 영업이익이 얼마예요
1억 6천 1억 6천 그러니까
임대료가 2억인데
기타 뭐 재산세 내고 건물 관리비
내고 뭐 내고 모내고 하니까 1억
6천만원 거의 5천 나가는
그러면 은행은 영업이익이랑 뭐랑
비교해 본다고요이자 이자리요이 회사는
이자가 얼마예요
이거는 대표님이라면이 회사에 돈
빌려주고 싶어요
[웃음]
똑같은 거예요 어 내가 막상 돈을
빌려주려고 하니까이
회사가 매출액이 2억인데 이런저런
어쨌든 이런 비용들을 안 쓸 순
없잖아 그죠 다 쓰고 남는 돈이 1억
6천밖에 안 돼
근데 내가이 사람한테 돈을 빌려주면
1년에 한 2억 5천원 나올 것 같아
근데 돈을 빌려줘요 안 빌려주고
9천 정도 빠지는 거 같은데요
그러면 이야기하겠죠 어 이거 한 9천
정도 비는데
원하시는 대출 앱 정도는 안 나오실
것 같아요 한 제가 64억이 아니라
한
40억 정도만 빌려드릴게요 이렇게
나오겠죠 그게 그냥 당연한 상식이죠
상식 근데 여러분들이 처음에 회사를
만들었을 때 신설법인 이런게 없잖아요
재무제표가 없으니까 그때는 뭐를 보는
거냐면요
여러분들의 소득과 여러분들의 신용과
여러분들이 매입하려는 건물의
담보가치를 본 거예요 없잖아요
볼게 없 보니까 어이 건물 담보가액은
얼마지 그리고 어 돈을 빌려주면
결국에는 법인에 빌려준다는 거는
주주한테 빌려주는 거고 대표이사한테
빌려주는 건데이 사람의 소득이 어느
정도지 그걸 보는 거거든요
신설법이나곤 좀 달라요 이제 법인의
연차가 쌓이고 이런 데이터들이 누적이
되면 이런 질문지표를 가지고 오라고
합니다 그리고 나서는 뭐가 나오냐면
뭐 잡손실 이런 것들이 나는 이건
사실 금액이 크진 않아요 그래서
마지막으로 이제 설명드릴 건 당기순
손실 이런 거죠
임대료가 있었어요 건물을 사게 되면은
부동산업을 운영하게 되면
써야 되는 비용들이 있어요
재산세 그걸 차감하게 영업이익이에요
영업이익에서이자 비용을 차감하면은
당기순 손실이냐 단기 순이 나와요이
회사는 당연히 손실이겠죠
939 그래서
손익계산을 볼 때는 딱 세 군데만
보면 됩니다
첫 번째 제일 밑에 아까
질문 상태표도 제일 밑에요
단기 순손실 이게 김수냐 양수냐
근데
단기 순손실은 3년 연속 음수냐
근데이 회사는 작년에는 양수였어요
올해 이제 첫 번째
음수
그러니까 두 번째 요건은 안 되는
거고 3년 연속은 아니니까 세 번째
영업이익과이자 비용을 비교해 봐야
돼요
매출액과 비교해보는게 아니라
영업이익과 순수익과이자 비용이 얼마냐
지금 같은 경우는 얼마죠
근데 영업이익과이자 비용도 한 번
해당된다고 부시지무 기업이다 이렇게
보진 않아요 2년 연속 3년 연속은
결손날 거 같으면 빨리 조치를 해야
돼 조치를 해야 돼 그러니까 이런
거잖아요 2년 연속이잖아요
그래 올해는 어쩔 수 없다 다
지나갔다 그럼 23년 어떻게 할지
사실 대책을 세워야 돼 그러니까
이거를 모르는 사람들도 되게 많거든
친구가 다 들어갔고 아니 신고
들어가는 건 그렇다 칩시다
근데 어쨌든 내가 이런 상황에
처했는지는 알아야 될 거 아니에요
내가 과연 이게 지금
은행에서 어떻게 나를 바라볼까 내가
이게 만기가 됐을 때 과연 은행이
나한테 또 돈을 빌려줄까 그래서
앞으로 계획을 짜기 위해서도 대처를
하기 위해서도 반드시 알아야 돼요
그래서 사실 이렇게까지
디테일하게
고민하시는 분이 없어요 없어요
왜냐면은 제가 아까도 설명드렸다시피
고민을 안 해도 되는 행복한 세상에
살았어요
사실 뭐 누구도이
고민을 안 했죠 사실 뭐 저도 뭐
이런게 있지만
고객한테 이런 걸 알려드려도 고객이
입장에서 보면 어차피 해당 안 되네
하고 넘어가면 저도 뭐 굳이 알려드릴
필요 없잖아요
근데 이제는 보면은 어 이거는 좀
알려 드려야겠다 올해 어쨌든 2년
연속에서 첫 번째 해당이 되셔서 전체
은행에서 바라보는 부시지문 기업에는
해당되지 않지만 어쨌든 한번 걸린
거잖아요 23년은 잘해야 될 거
아니야인지는 해야 되는 거고 대책을
좀 세우셔야 되는 거야 만약에 해당이
안 됐더라도 어느 정도 여유가
있는지도 알고 계시면 좋죠 왜냐면
내가 올해는 예를 들자면 영업이익이
한 1억 6천이에요 근데이자 비용
1억 5천이야 올
예를 들자면 저한테
10억을 일부 갚으셔야 될 것 같다는
말은
어떤 말이죠 아 이거는 난 15도
없는데
그러면은
진짜 좀 괜찮은 매물이 또 나올 수도
있겠네요 그렇죠 저는 아마 이런게
이제 올해부터
데이터가 이제 하나씩 찍혀 나올 것
같아요
그러면은 작년부터 올랐고
그러면은 올해 첫 번째 치킨 회사가
있을 거고 23년도 이거를 못 지키는
회사가 나올 거고 그러면
25년 그런게 이제 저는 전이가 될
거라고 생각을 해요
알겠습니다 오늘
회계사님이 정말 좋은 말씀 많이
해주셨는데
혹시 내가
2020년도에 그 건물을 투자했거나
아니면 2019년도 그때 투자하신
그런 신규 법인 같은 경우에는 반드시
좀 이걸 확인해 보실 필요가 있어요
진짜 급한 거예요 이거 사실
재무제표가 나왔냐 3월 31일까지라서
이제 한창만 이제 마무리 단계일텐데
재무지표가 나왔냐 한번 보자 이거를
확인하셔야 될 것 같습니다
진짜 진짜 급한 겁니다 이거 당장
전화해서
재무제표 달라 그래서 제가 저희가
말씀드린
부분을
확인하기시고 뭐 이제
그러면 2022년 다 간 거
아니냐라고 생각하시는데
2022년만 살 건 아니잖아요
23년까지 남아있는 거라서 뭐 지나간
건 지나간 거고 야 그러면 23년에
우리는 어떻게 될까 아직 23년이란
건지 뭐 두 달
밖에 안 지났기 때문에 23년을
위해서라도 22년 재무제표는 반드시
한번 확인하고
넘어가셔야 될 것 같습니다
하겠습니다 오늘 영상은 여기까지
하고요 또
추가적으로 뭐 궁금하신거나 이런 거
있으시면
회계사님한테 이메일
쪽에 남겨 드릴테니까 보내주시면 좋을
것 같습니다